well this is interesting when the bidens
moved into the white house
they brought their two dogs with them
champ and major
there they are beautiful german
shepherds well here's the thing
when there are dogs in the white house
the secret service has a special canine
security detail
it protects the dogs yeah i'm curious
what it's like protecting the
president's dog so
i wanted to find out joining me now k9
special agent
james duncan hello agent duncan
hello mr o'brien now let me get this
straight sir you're the secret service
agent assigned to protect
champ and major is that correct yes sir
that's correct and as a matter of fact
i've got
i've got champ and major right here at
my feet as we speak sir oh great this is
cool can we see them is it
is that possible i'm afraid not you know
it is a security thing
and also i am i'm not allowed to uh
tip the uh the camera down towards my
lap anymore on zoom calls right right
that's been people have been getting in
trouble for that yeah so let's get to
the point if you're a canine security
agent
what were you doing the last four years
i mean famously the trumps did not have
dogs
no sir they did not have a dog but they
did have eric trump sir and i was
assigned to him
all right but eric trump is not a dog
nobody said eric trump was a dog
okay people like dogs people want to be
around dogs dogs can learn new things
but we did feel that there was enough
psychological overlap between
dogs and eric that uh that i could work
with him okay well
what do you mean by that well eric trump
is uh
he's energetic he's eager to please he's
ployle as hell i gotta tell you and he
loves to chase a frisbee
and he is capable of being a very very
good boy
oh okay so there i see that there's yeah
i see
yeah the first time i met him he was
extremely suspicious of me but
as soon as he got up there and sniffed
my crotch we uh
we became friends and uh you know soon
thereafter
he was sleeping at the foot of my bed
every night i'm sorry eric
slept at the foot of your bed yes sir
nope
unless i had a lady spend the night then
it was uh back in the crate
ah yeah i gotta you can't have them
roaming around actually you know
uh i couldn't ask for a nicer boy if i'm
being honest with you
and i and i brought some pictures i'd
like to show you if you'd like
yeah let's see these photos this is
great great so this is
uh this is eric on the uh on the first
warm day of spring
actually got eight nipples that's odd
yeah yes sir yes sir and he loved having
his tummy rubbed
oh he loved it here's another one i took
on the fourth of july oh he looked
scared
the uh the fireworks really freaked him
out it's actually
it's the only time i saw him express his
anal glands yeah okay we don't need to
hear
everything you could have skipped that
part okay yeah yes sir okay oh well
here's a happier time
uh this is a photo of eric with his
family
i'm sorry is that a plastic cone on his
head yes sir he uh he got ear mites
after uh after playing with uh steve
bannon and uh
we tried to put a uh a cream on his ear
but he kept rubbing it off and yeah
yeah well uh well anyway eric's gone now
and
uh you have two real dogs to look after
how is it different now
it's it's very different sir first uh
champion major
never tried to hump my leg and uh you
know eric was always getting after it i
had to use a squirt gun to get him off
me
let me just check here yeah yeah both
these guys still have their testicles ah
very good and seen
special agent james duncan thank you for
for spending your time and
best of luck to you thank you sir thank
you for having me conan